but what about like when your
ex-girlfriend is that you may get an
abortion can you forget that kid oh no I
still can't to this day
[Music]
have you guys ever left something on the
plane
yeah nope a Hydro Flask I just bought it
too damn like the day before I was like
I'm gonna buy a hydro flash because this
is the longest flight I've ever been on
and I want to make sure I have water
left it on the plane so it didn't have
it for the plane ride back damn I didn't
feel to lose like a 40 water bottle
what's up that sucks that's a very big
thing to say
it was black too I put a cool sticker on
it too what kind of sticker was it the
tiger belly sticker I left my entire
first gen PSP on the plane back when
that was new when it was new that's like
200 right yeah I left it on the planet
more like that's your whole life at the
time you know how you put it in a little
pocket thing and then you go to sleep
and I just got up and start going what
were you playing at that time uh it was
uh the metal gear
um PSP oh nice it's a good one it wasn't
Crash Bandicoot bro oh no
um how about in an Uber have you guys
ever left anything yes damn dude you be
leaving [ __ ] everywhere a car key oh I
was gonna get an Uber you got a car bruh
so here's the story it was the first
time ever I was performing like a rap
show in California so my homies from AZ
came down we stayed over at this uh spot
over by the airport and so like we were
gonna drink and stuff right so I didn't
want to drive so we left my car in like
one of those parking structures by the
airport it's like black and yellow or
whatever and um so we took an Uber there
I think it was a Los La Cienega or Los
globos or some [ __ ] like that the in
Silver Lake yeah oh the show yeah and
then so so we went there the Uber
drivers took a took us we went went back
to the hotel the next morning I wake up
and we couldn't find my car key anywhere
so I called The Uber driver on my a is
by chance my key in your car and it was
I was like oh dude can you come back and
bring it I'll throw you some money he's
like oh I'm at Coachella right now so I
really had to wait like a whole another
day so we just stayed in that hotel for
one another day and he came back and I
gave him 40 bucks and he looked all
unhappy and [ __ ] but I was like hey
remember that time we were looking we
were in Vegas
and uh we were staying at the Red Rock
and we left and we were looking for his
GoPro because we had a bunch of footage
on there
and we couldn't find it
all day and then where was it it was
ended up being your fanny pack oh yeah
I actually lost a GoPro on an airplane
dang just leaving it there yeah I just
left it in the same type of [ __ ] PSP
pop they must find some really great
stuff in those pouches I lost my first
ever digital camera you know there's
like a little Cyber Shot type thing yeah
like it was a can one of those Canon
ones that was all the rage I got for
Christmas and I was going on I was I
think we were going to Europe for the
first time I'm gonna take all these
crazy pictures got on the plane I was a
little buzzed getting off the plane I'm
like where's the camera called the
airline no sorry we don't have it I try
to get back on the plane oh you can't do
that once you're off you can't do that
even if you barely [ __ ] step past the
door that's crazy because you can't even
be like yo I'm in 24c just reaching the
thing and grab it they're like nope this
is before iPhone pictures and I was just
like all right this trip socks too
there's gonna be no memories because
they keep that [ __ ] because my mom used
to work in an airline and she used to
get stuff from the law stuff out all the
time what kind of [ __ ] would you get uh
she got like this [ __ ]
um I think sweater or like windbreaker
she's like yeah you know like stuff like
that she was like oh my my son would
love this you know because like nobody
claims it yeah nobody everybody left
dude that's a great point and after like
a week they just like they just take it
what else that can't be it windbreakers
bro come on want you no that's that was
the one thing I remember is that she
took my brother my brother my GoPros
PSPs
she got a Windbreak no she got a hoodie
what was what position did your mom have
for the airline um she worked at the
counter so then it's she's not seeing
that stuff it's probably what people
just the cleaners are getting yeah they
got all the good [ __ ] like here's a cool
windbreaker if you want it yeah that's
probably what it's a digital camera in
the pocket oh sure my brother he's a
mechanic and when people go and buy new
cars or whatever they're like trade in
their old one or like they'll sell their
car to it but a lot of people do it and
they forget a [ __ ] ton of stuff and then
like legally it's the the dealerships
now so then the dealership says like oh
you guys [ __ ] whatever take whatever
you like what's ever in there so
sometimes there's been like snowboards
he said there's been like [ __ ] MP3
players cameras and [ __ ] like that in
these what about windbreakers I think a
couple windbreakers he had some fresh
ass ones when I was there it's a hot
Commodities these are hot in the streets
bro this is a perfect temp it's like
you'll be warm for sure yeah but but
it's not too warm not too warm I don't
like being you know I don't like real
talk about back in the day though if you
would have [ __ ] got a windbreaker
instead like Nautica and [ __ ]
yeah so the reason I was asking you guys
is because in Florida this Granddad of
he's 62 he returned his rental car to
the rental car place and forgot his
granddaughter in it um they get to keep
her they get to keep her
until further notice
why don't you give me that look like
something bad happened
oh no something bad happens oh no come
on Anthony
Come on Anthony me the leader
the kid think bad could have happened
because the temperature was so high that
her life was at risk but they were able
to they were able to notice her before
you know anything where which which uh
company was this at our price probably
hurts Enterprise let's just say it's
hurts yeah they do the walk around
hurts you just drop your car off we're
gonna go up yeah it's probably it's
probably hurts yeah maybe because then
yeah they would have seen her during the
walk around which is yeah yeah don't
yeah let me don't they unless she was in
the trunk
oh what oh Jesus hey good job Nick right
that's a Nicky right I wouldn't say that
thank you I mean I would say that
because I'm Nick I know like none of us
here has kids but from what I've noticed
and what I've read a lot about there are
instances where parents just kind of
forget for sure or grandparents you just
forget your kid but how old is this guy
62. that's too young for him to be
forgetting oh no I'll be forgetting [ __ ]
Bro not that it's a sign of old age it's
just like a thing you your mind is just
on other [ __ ] you just forget yeah
Anthony that's ageism what you just said
right there nah that is a little ageless
and I think old people forget stuff dude
that's why oh um have you ever been
forgotten as a kid by your parents in
any way shape or form pretty sure I have
because I've been lost like many times
maybe I wandered off no you want it off
bro in a windbreaker though I'm telling
me you can little old can wasn't just
like walking around
I bet you're a curious little kid you
don't think you're curious of course but
you were curious there's many times my
parents go you know yeah I think there's
got to be something with that I know
none of us are parents yet but I swear
to God Home Alone one of the best
selling movies of all time there's
something uh that people are relating to
yeah and the fact that she couldn't
remember that one I feel like maybe like
for because Kevin home alone was she
like that was like a whole [ __ ] like
day or whatever and she forgot her kid
right or whatever I mean that was a
different state it's because the power
went out dude well you get over
overwhelmed with stuff and you're just
not thinking about it for the key moment
that you know you miss out the best
thing in the home alone is when the
uncle goes look what you did you little
jerk and uncle's a piece of [ __ ] he has
like no business even existing yeah I
love it uh no I don't think I'd forget a
kid you don't think you would I don't
know if I went home alone they had like
12 kids
if there's a but if there's a ton of
kids I can see how like maybe you might
you know miscount and think you like
count because my mom has done that
before because when she got remarried my
stepdad had two daughters and then she
had her three boys uh and then our
little sister so like they would do a
head count like how many people were
here all right cool but what about like
when your ex-girlfriends that you may
get an abortion can you forget that kid
oh no I still can't to this day
just in case anybody wants to chime in
and you know throw their name in the Hat
as well and be like oh yeah me too right
no no all right
I teach Jiu Jitsu but but also though
like you can't forget a kid if it's just
one kid you can't forget one kid I still
think parents how old was the uh
granddaughter five this is the moment
where Ryan goes like well you didn't
know that the grandpa had dementia was
she asleep if she was asleep okay but
even then it's like nah bro
grandfather oh that's that's hard that's
kind of tough though bro like when
you're taking off your seatbelt you
can't see like the in the peripherals or
the Carson
is not your kid it's your kid's kid so
you're probably your level of care is
probably not your level of care
it's like well he's not my kid I don't
care about it that much no
no don't care it was way low once you
accept the responsibility the second
they get in your car you have one even
if it's not your kid you have 100 care
right no you're supposed to that's why
is that a Tamagotchi it is you'd be
forgetting a feature Tamagotchi no I
just fed it right now wow but that's not
your kid man you know what you didn't
give birth to that dude what I'm saying
is like for other people like maybe they
might not care because it's not their
actual kid it's their kids kid you know
I think that's true but that's also wild
so would you not be as mad at them if
they forgot I don't know what are you
talking if I was the the dad or whatever
of that kid I'd be like Grandpa you're
gonna have to earn this trust again it
might take you until you die yeah bro
you guys have never left your food or
drink on top of your car I mean but
that's a fruit or drink but you don't
care about Panda Express no no actually
no I would never because I cherish those
things
so if I put something on top I know I've
never done that I just did that [ __ ]
actually a couple days ago yeah that's
your Mo though you know you kind of
forget stuff fell off the top of my car
it's all dented now and [ __ ]
yeah
40 watt
why do you feel about that no this one
was more it's one of the bigger ones
I bet you if it was a hundred dollar
water bottle you probably would not
forget that [ __ ] not because a water
bottle don't mean that much to me but if
it was your kid's water bottle what oh
yeah
there's that [ __ ] going with me
everywhere bruh I have a feeling like
we're in for uh a surprise because I
think when you're a parent this
autopilot thing kicks in yeah and you
can you get blind spots with like
awareness I'm sure because you got so
much to think about if Bert was here he
could [ __ ] chime in but he lost his
privilege so we I guess because his
autopilot for his family kicked in so he
stops [ __ ] caring about his business
he forgot I don't think I ever remember
my parents ever forgetting about me
anywhere that's good that's called
erasing it from your memory so you don't
scar your future self and
self-preservation that's true
this is what they would do when they
want to punch me sometimes they go to a
parking lot if we were in the car and
they yelled me they kicked me out the
car and then they slowly start backing
out and driving away and anytime I
didn't give in because I thought I was
tough I was like I know you're playing a
trick they would just keep going farther
until I once I started [ __ ] crying
and [ __ ] I got to come back every time
you know what my mommy's do to me as a
kid this is back in like Singapore when
my mom was living there and we were
living with her for a little bit I think
I was probably like five or six seven I
think they would they would go like
shopping and they didn't want to take me
because I was probably annoying yeah a
little brat and they're like I was like
you want to come and and then I'd be
like yeah yeah she's like go get your
shoes and then I go get my shoes I come
back and they're gone emotional damage
low-key low-key look damn that [ __ ] to
this day still kind of hurts my feelings
bro Nick was in there tying his shoes
all excited and she was like [ __ ] that
he's like Loop swoop pool and then he
goes out yeah and then I just being
molded all the time bro you think that
affected me in my my adult life yeah
dude in what way it explains everything
I don't trust you shut up Ryan I can't
at least you get close
let me in your life man
[Music]
[Music]